bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'actu
d'abord cette information sociale des
salariés de psa poissy en colère contre
le montant de leurs primes de
participation qu'il juge trop faible
entre 10 et 18 euros ils ont débrayé
mercredi dernier et la cgt entend lancer
un plus vaste mouvement de mobilisation
politique maintenant christine boutin
conseillère générale des yvelines sera
bien candidate aux européennes avec son
nouveau mouvement force vie elle nous
détaille son programme clair cambier
jonathan willeman
un changement de civilisation c'est ce
que souhaite mettre en place christine
boutin et son nouveau mouvement force
vie première étape les européennes on
mai prochain l'actuelle conseillère
générale des yvelines a lancé ce
mercredi sa liste pour l'île de france
se décrivant comme une européenne
convaincue elle propose de remettre
l'humain au centre de la société dans
son programme on retrouve la défense de
l'embryon la reprise en main politique
et de la banque centrale européenne ou
encore l'instauration d'un revenu de
base entre 450 et 500 euros par adulte
force vie se présente comme un mouvement
citoyen la belle au dessus des
appartenances politiques et religieuses
que ce soit l'ump que ce soit le ps où
que ce soit le front national ils sont
tous dans le même système ils sont tous
dans cette réalité ou la personne
humaine devient secondes nous ce que
nous voulons c'est réhabiliter l'homme
notre priorité elle est là et nous irons
jusqu'au bout et ça ira plus loin que
les européennes de toute façon ce
nouveau label n'est pas une surprise
elle avait notamment justifié sa
démission au poste de présidente du
parti chrétien-démocrate en juillet
dernier par la volonté de s'investir au
niveau européen voici chose faite
christine boutin s'est entouré de 29
colistiers qui pour beaucoup font leur
entrée dans le domaine politique parmi
eux neuf yvelinois dont bénédicte de
dinechin en cinquième position engagés
dans ce mouvement suite à son refus de
la loi taubira sur le mariage pour tous
marino il est lui aussi opposé lui même
homosexuel il avait créé la polémique
par ses essais sur l'homosexualité le
catholicisme force vis ça dépasse le
clivage droite gauche ça dépasse ça
dépasse aussi le clivage sur
l'orientation sexuelle des personnes on
met l'homme au centre et c'est assez
fort que le grand meeting qui va avoir
lieu de force vis soit le jour de la
journée mondiale contre l'homophobie le
17 mai parce que en fait moi non plus je
gérais je viens de comprendre un moyen
pour christine boutin de contrebalancer
ses propos critiqués sur l'homosexualité
dans une interview au magazine charles
indiqué début avril l'homosexualité est
une abomination
mais pas assez pour l'inter lgbt qui a
porté plainte pour diffamation et
incitation à la haine les élections
européennes se déroule en un seul tour
le 25 mai
les ressortissants algériens appelés aux
urnes pour élire leur prochain président
dans les yvelines quatre bureaux vote
vote était à la disposition des
électeurs à poissy mantes la jolie
versailles et trappes donc vous voyez
sur ces images à la maison des familles
attrape la commune compte environ 3500
inscrits pour ces élections
présidentielles six candidats se
présentent dont le président sortant
abdelaziz bouteflika archi-favori rachid
ouali le responsable du bureau de vote
était au micro de violer yolaine torres
était mardi dernier des élections est
close depuis jeudi soir dans l'écouté
nous votons avril gens savent ce que
c'est que voter c'est en même temps un
droit c'est en même temps un devoir
civique ce qui nous a satisfaits cette
fois ci c'est que beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes se sont rendus dans
les urnes
pendant toute cette semaine le temps des
vacances une soixantaine de jeunes
trappistes a suivi un stage de danse un
peu particulier attrape un stage de
danse moderne proposé par une compagnie
américaine détruite en compagnie un
travail en partenariat avec l'ambassade
des états unis les services culturels de
la ville et la complète la compagnie
black blanc beur un programme intitulé
dance into connect
- épouse
ils dansent s'exprime sous le regard
d'une chorégraphe américaine robin fait
partie de bertry dance company une
compagnie new-yorkaise qui six mois de
l'année arpente les villes du monde
entier pour proposer des stages de danse
et gratuit hier à belfast en irlande
demain à calcutta en inde et pendant
cette semaine de vacances ici à 30 à
l'école de musique et de danse pour
yasmine et cyrine que du bonheur
c'est bizarre parce que j'ai pas j'ai
jamais vu des danseurs américains et
c'est la première fois que j'en vois
et bah
ils sont gentils j'aime bien bouger et
montrer mon talent en fait et je danse
depuis tout petit ça soit de la danse
classique hip hop etc déjà je vais
apprendre l'anglais mieux que oui
j'apprends comme ça j'essaie dé moi etc
et je peux encore romain tri l'est
encore plus dans la danse
travailler en groupe d la
et
savoir écouter autres les idées des
autres
l'idée c'est de travailler 2 le second
centrée sur les forts ensemble
la cohésion de groupe pour dépasser
leurs propres limites et se rendre
compte
des faits dance company a été créé en 76
dans un quartier assez défavorisé du sud
de manhattan les cinq danseurs
principaux qui composent la troupe sont
tous enseignants et chorégraphe ils ont
les origines très diverses clément et
ghanéens carmen et canadiennes shon
vient de la barbade mirail les texanes
ici il apprécie aussi la mixité des
élèves
ce que je trouve formidable c'est la
variété du groupe qui est très
international en discutant avec les
élèves je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
venaient des quatre coins du monde
d'afrique de l'europe de partout donc
humainement c'est très enrichissant
cette diversité
une semaine de stage une représentation
unique et gratuite ce samedi soir à la
merise de trappes l'accomplissement de
cinq jours de travail et d'énergie mise
en commun
à la verrière les familles se met aux
fourneaux la municipalité organisait un
concours de cuisine afin de récompenser
l'équipe qui réalisera le meilleur
dessert nous sommes rendus sur place
pour la première sélection
réaliser le meilleur dessert en 1h30
c'est le défi que se sont lancés ces
trois équipes organisé par le service
jeunesse et maisons de quartier de la
verrière ce concours incite notamment à
cuisiner en famille c'est parce qu'à la
maison j'ai presque jamais cuisiné et de
classer une chance des cuisines et
avec ma grand mère parmi les ingrédients
imposés pour cette première sélection
des pommes des feuilles de brick des
spéculoos ou encore de la crème anglaise
à chacun sa méthode mais en fait on sait
pas trop pour l'instant c'est la
profitation verra
d'autres en revanche sont déjà la
recette bien aux têtes un millefeuille à
la pomme avec une canne anglaise et il
comportait des compactes marie va
s'adapter puis j'ai ma petite fille
qu'avec moi qui mène donc 1 pékin sommes
bien rôdés l'équipe du ria et de sa
petite-fille dresse son dessert en
premier ne reste plus qu'à patienter
jusqu'à l'annoncé des résultats c'est la
surprise du chef va bien
aurillac et yousra sont finalement les
gagnantes de cette première sélection
est le rendez vous pour la grande finale
le 24 avril prochain
toute cette semaine vous le savez nous
vous avons proposé une série de
reportages consacrés aux motards de la
police yvelinoise je vous propose les
deux derniers épisodes pour mieux
connaître les différentes facettes du
métier alors ce soir peut-être l'un des
rôles les plus emblématiques de ces
motards les escortes anthony rech
jonathan vilma sandrine fontaine
à chacun sa moto et sa spécialité
cet après-midi-là axel et camille sont
chargés de l'escort d'un détenu
particulièrement surveillé l'homme s'est
déjà évadé d'une prison de province en
2008 a été hospitalisé sous contrainte
pour des problèmes de violence et de
comportement très difficile dans une
mission si sensible l'erreur est
interdite c'est la partie dont on ne te
plus concentré on doit être on est
vraiment au top de nos compétences mais
voilà on doit être vraiment là on peut
pas se permettre d'y aller à moitié il
faut vraiment être bien concentré être
très vigilant vraiment les yeux très
ouvert le regard très écartés c'est
effectivement c'est ce qu'a pool de plus
valorisant le prisonnier se trouve à
l'intérieur de ce véhicule léger les
deux policiers savent qu'ils peuvent se
faire attaquer à tout moment par un
élément extérieur qui voudraient le
faire évader ou le tuer axel et camille
ont reconnu plusieurs itinéraires avant
de rejoindre la maison d'arrêt de poissy
le but des motards ne jamais s'arrêter
être toujours en mouvement pour limiter
les risques d' attaque
sur plus de 20 km axel et camille vont
mettre potentiellement leur vie en
danger ils mettront un quart d'heure
pour arriver au tribunal de grande
instance de versailles ça roule vite
on doit vraiment avoir la gestion de ce
qui est devant nous la gestion de ce qui
est derrière nous en plus donc avec un
pour les dps gestion de l'environnement
donc sécurité faire attention qu et des
voitures avec des vitres teintées quand
on voit la de trois voitures des gens
bizarres sur la route sur un épais son
maître la ville devient danger voilà
potentiellement
donc oui effectivement il faut être
vraiment dedans concentré pas pas
stressé mais concentré prêt à donner le
maximum et de danse mission accomplie le
convoi est arrivé à l'heure pour la
confrontation avec le juge le véhicule
d'animation pedn pénitentiaire ou de
l'équipe de police qui transporte le
rapporte doit jamais s'arrêter là
toujours pouvoir être en mouvement pour
voir c'est ma dé circuler c'est très
important pour est en danger si on
immobile on est en danger outre les
prisonniers les motards de la police
nationale escorte également en urgence
les véhicules du samu et des
personnalités publiques la section
yvelinoise réalise en moyenne près de
300 escorte chaque année
et puis le dernier volet de notre série
de reportages qu'il soit donc gardiens
de la paix brigadier ou officiers les
motards de la police nationale oeuvre au
quotidien pour préserver la sécurité des
usagers de la route mais face aux
infractions des automobilistes ils
mettent parfois leur vie en danger
cette spécialité moto de la police
nationale requiert l'excellence où
l'erreur n'est pas permise sur la route
des compétences que les policiers
doivent réviser régulièrement comme l'
usage de leurs armes sur la moto en cas
de situation difficile
l'unité de la formation motocycliste
urbaine des yvelines est sous la
responsabilité du capitaine le d'ars cet
ancien militaire a notamment mené
l'escadron de motos dernier défilé du 14
juillet sur les champs elysées s'ils
mesurent l'importance du rôle de ces
sommes sur la route ils se heurtent
parfois à leur propre ligne comme nous
sommes là pour lutter contre
l'insécurité routière est contre eh bien
les comportements
que nous on qualifie d' accidentogène
des autres usagers c'est à dire
notamment les excès de vitesse les
choses comme ça il faut que nous on soit
capable d'aller au delà de certaines
limites tout en restant en sécurité
pouvoir faire
quoi qu'il en soit il faut qu'on
intervienne mais effectivement il faut
trouver la juste lui pour ne pas le
provoquer poussé à la faute et provoque
un accident de plus en plus les motards
interviennent pour des grands excès de
vitesse un fléau qui prend de
l'importance sur les routes yvelinoise
mais la majorité les usagers
respecterait plus les règles qu'il y a
quelques années la prise de conscience
elle n'est pas dans le danger et les ans
les conséquences les gens font plus
attention parce qu'ils ont tenté de
perdre leurs permis et pas d'avoir le
permis à points
à payer les amendes imposées conomique
étant là souvent c'est la loterie permis
ça devient difficile pour les travailler
pour en trouver au moins ça a le mérite
d'entraîner une prise de conscience
malheureusement on n'est pas encore dans
la prise de conscience du danger de la
route qu'ils soient gardiens de la paix
brigadier ou officiers qu'ils effectuent
des escortes où des patrouilles cette
trentaine de motards oeuvre au quotidien
pour la sécurité des usagers et pour
faire diminuer le nombre de tués sur les
routes en 2013
quarante sept personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans le département leur combat
continue
et puis cette série de reportages vous
pouvez évidemment retrouver tous tous
ces reportages sur le site internet de
télé fil 78 68 l'aktu est terminé merci
de votre attention
retour de l'information en direct ce
sera le mardi et 22 avril et lundi de
pâques oblige dans quelques instants
c'est le 7-8 week-end il sera notamment
question des 20 ans de l'espace
rambouillet bonne soirée